Why does he sound so panicked? Do I have this on like 2x? Bro,
you can hear the panic in his voice. He is like actually panicked
as [__] This guy is like the biggest rat on planet
Earth. Actual biggest rat on planet Earth. Okay. Nuts. It's nuts,
man. >> You've literally got his little cartoon character
freaking the out about your name being on screen.
[music]
>> I'm ready to move forward to the Nu stuff. Okay, Nux
did his full response today. Nux Taku response to Nandro's
recently. Someone made a hit piece on me, but I did see some
of the clips that were floating around and uh from what I saw,
it was some of the most disingenuous I think ever. Uh, and
uh, the most disingenuous the what he means to say is it was
the most wellsourced shot on my career I've ever seen and I have
no response. So, I'm just going to say it was like
I I literally couldn't possibly respond. So, I'm going to say
that it was like fake or or made up or something. >> And
I've gotten so many people that I've talked to that also watched,
you know, either clips of it or some of it and also said it was
like the most biggest stretch biggest stretches and disingenuous
of all time. All right.
Oh, I would love to see those DMs. People you're close to have
said that it was really disingenuous in the biggest stretch of
all time. Could you quote some of the people who said that just
for SC, you know, I just want to talk to those people maybe?
I I like have minor disagreements with them. But I I think these
people should be put on some kind of list. All the ones who said
it was like really disingenuous. Can we get those people on a
list, please? >> Right now, I've covered and discussed
most of this in the past a million times. I've made videos um
I made videos back in the day making fun of weird and [__]
that came out of Japan. Uh and I do regret it as I've also talked
about many times. All right. Uh I do regret making >> Why
does he sound so panicked? Do I have this on like 2x,
>> bro? You can hear the panic in his voice. He is like
actually panicked as holy. Hold on. >> I made videos back
in the day making fun of weird and that came out of Japan. Uh
and I do regret it as I've also talked about many times. All
right. Uh, I do regret making content like that. Be and and I
do regret it. I I regret all of it. I regret it >> because
I quite literally have evolved. I've grown. I'm pretty much anti.
This doesn't look like uh this doesn't look like it's about you
showing, you know, like lollycon to people. This doesn't look
like that. This seems to be Discord logs. Nucks. Why are you
talking about the weird you showed kids?
That's that is a problem, too. But hey, that seems to be, you
know, this is about Discord logs, man. This is very different
in general. Now, my entire stance on all that changed years ago.
Um, however, however, I never
years a How many years >> Never endorsed any of the weird
that I would comment on. I would make fun of it. All right. It
was never an endorsement at all. And these people are all liars
and disingenuous. Now, the new
It was never an endorsement at all.
Oh, boy. Oh, boy. Okay. Um, I'm trying to think. Never an endorsement
at all. Okay.
I
do feel like there were lots of places where you pretty explicitly
endorsed this stuff. I wonder did he ever get into a argument
specifically? I'm trying to think back. We'll go through I think
Nicandros also goes through some of this. So, we'll go to that
in a little bit and we'll get his debunking of this. I'm I'm
almost positive this guy's explicitly supported before. Okay.
>> The new angle that people are taking is that I was grooming
people in a Discord. uh a no that you set up a discord and then
profited from
basically a minor who you knew was a minor who there's basically
no way you could argue wasn't a minor. No way you could argue
you didn't know they were minor rather like they literally they
literally said their age. People everybody knew their age. You
may have been you'd have to be arguing you're the only person
in that discord who didn't know their age. Literally everybody
knew their age. Okay. And then when that person was like, "Hey,
I want, you know, a channel." You're like, "Okay, I'll make a
porn channel." And then they upped their subscription to you.
Why? I've never groomed anyone ever. And they've never had any
evidence of me grooming anyone ever. All right. So, it's a lot
of uh a lot of implications that get thrown out. So, this is
the most viral clip of the video that I found um with the most
serious allegation that I saw. So, um let's uh let's watch this
clip. I'll play the clip and I'll give you my >> The NSFW
channel wasn't there from the start. We can trace its creation
to this exchange from October 15th, 2018 where we can see this
user who from
>> They're saying that I engaged sex with with a 15-year-old
in 2018. 2018
18's in the year, guys. >> 8 years ago. >> Now on
will be called Red Repeatedly asking Knox to create it. If we
look at the time and date of these messages, the >> For
the record, um, this Discord server was made in 2018. It was
a Patreon only Discord server. All right, it was not a public
Discord server. >> Dude, what does that have to do with
anything? Already off to a horrible start.
They had to pay me. The child had to pay me. Okay. And it was
a small Discord server. So, like, if I were to argue that it
was like really big and I couldn't manage it, that's not a good
argument with a private Discord server, is it? Literally, it
was a private server where I could obviously track most of the
conversations that happened. >> it was Patreon only. All
right. Anyway, for for don donors. Oh, and by the way, I have
a Patreon link in the description. YOU CAN SUPPORT MY WORK. THAT
WOULD BE REALLY GREAT. Thank you very much. I really bad idea
to send people to something that's obviously not going to exist
in a very short amount of time. Okay? There's absolutely zero
way that this doesn't violate the Patreon terms of service. As
soon as they're made aware, as soon as somebody up high enough
in Patreon is made aware, that's going away. Don't ask for donations
there. Knucks is very, very bad instincts. Okay. Given where
you live, you're sending money to somewhere that they're certainly
going to confiscate >> Appreciate it. All right, but anyway.
So, yeah, continue. >> W channel was made 2 minutes late.
>> There is a note here saying absolutely nothing from
minors, by the way. No
>> Um, no, that's not what it says. That's not what it
says. Personal nudes. I from you or people, you know, content
of minors. content depicting minors or childlike adults not allowed.
Okay, it doesn't say no minors in the Discord. In fact, as it
will be evidenced in the video that you did approve of minors
in the Discord. Actually, you had a 16 plus rule for the Discord.
>> Nudes, no content of minor content >> Oh, wait.
That might have been the public discord minor content made by
minors. None of that. All right, just just to be clear.
In response to this, Red raised their Patreon pledge and KN gave
them a thumbs up. For a brief moment, let me take you to August
of >> This is the guy that made the video. If you want
to watch the full video, you should go watch it, by the way,
if you want. If you want to watch an hour and a half of this
guy um calling me a um with zero evidence that I'm a you can
watch this video. I think he actually is pretty careful about
not calling him a
like specifically. So Nucks, you know, this is this is in fact
it may be defamation,
right? I think Nantress explicitly didn't call him a right because
he didn't want that to be the dismissal of oh well you didn't
find out you didn't find info that he's so he accused you of
very specific things. One is early introduction that you knowingly
and with understanding the consequences introduced to a bunch
of like little kids. He might have even ignored the knowing the
consequences. You just gave evidence that you might know the
consequences, but you you exposed a bunch of young kids to sexual
imagery over and over and over again. And then from there,
you ran a Discord server, or I guess maybe earlier in the timeline,
you ran a Discord server where a 15-year-old was groomed and
that you were very active in that Discord. You were obviously
in VCs. You talked in that Discord often. you actually engaged
around the messages where this person was being encouraged to
drop out of school and where they I mean obviously they're the
one who asked you for the NSFW channel. >> Um that would
be great. Um go do that. All right. I'm not not trying to hide
that or anything. Just to be to be clear, all right, not not
putting it under the rug at all. Absolutely. If you want to go
watch it, go watch it. I will not be spending four hours reacting
to an hour and a half long video uh calling me a again and again
and again for things I've already addressed.
>> You've never addressed the Discord thing. You've never
addressed this thing right here. >> Naku is finally being
pressed about his past content and he was actually >> So,
to be clear, this is also incorrect. This is not when I was being
pressed for my past content. This was literally a video that
I made talking about my 10 years on YouTube cuz it was like my
10 year YouTube anniversary. All right. This was not like a response
to drama video as far as I remember. Maybe I'm mistaken. Very
important clarification. Thank you, Knox. Very important clarification.
Definitely not you panicking and just trying to find anything
to disagree with in this clip at the wrong video, but that's
what I thought. pushed into making a response. >> The biggest
shock to me to this day, entering the broader commentary sphere
was the dangers lurking around every corner in regards to children.
Children are not safe on the internet. I only became chronically
online after high school, but I couldn't imagine what it would
do to me if I was in some YouTubers's Discord server at the age
of 12 or 14. Yeah. So, um, as you could see, I addressed many
times that I, uh, that I regretted the fact that I would make
LWD content and back in the day. Uh to be honest, I've mentioned
that multiple times. Literally called it out in the past. >> Dude,
dude.
Dude. >> Uh but anywh who, moving on. Uh and this video
was uh it was like a 10-year anniversary. This was not like some
apology, whatever. Anywh who uh and also valid statement. I was
right.
>> You couldn't imagine. You don't need to. All right.
>> Red joined the server on September 7th. On day one,
they openly declared themselves to be 14 years old. >> I
didn't know about this. They would later claim to be 15 multiple
times, but as they >> I didn't know about this [laughter]
>> openly stated they were lying about their age. Red was
>> so they were lying about their age. >> Born in
200.
>> So uh look,
>> wait, is that even what is that even what Nandra said
there? I didn't know about this. >> Openly stated they
were lying about their age. Red was >> So they were lying
about their age. >> Born in 200.
>> So uh look man, I don't Wait, does he pause it? Does
he really pause it? Wait. Oh no. The clip restarts. Does the
clip really not include their actual age?
Yeah, they were literally 14. They were literally 14. That's
>> I don't know how a minor even got into the clip cuts
off there is
>> Oh, that's Shamu. What are you doing, man? Shamu, what
are you doing? Okay, but that's it's still very funny given like
there's no way he didn't go through it, right? Do you guys think
there's any way he didn't watch this video in full before deciding
to respond to just a
I feel like there's no shot, right? He had to have been aware.
So, he has to be aware here in my opinion that this person is
15. Sorry, they were 14, turning 15. No way he watched it.
I I don't see how he could have possibly not watched it, but
maybe mentioned this in the longer video. I'm not trying to say
that he tried to slander me on purpose over here. Um, but this
was a Patreon server. For those of you that are unaware, Patreon
servers >> No, he's very clear that it's Patreon >> Inherently
18 plus.
>> Because uh if you want to become a pat if you want to
join a creator's membership as a patron um or provide membership
as a creator, you must be at least 18 years old or have permission
from a parent or guardian. All right. Um quite lit.
>> Okay. What if they what if they just told their parents
they wanted to join that Discord? Yeah. So, or have or have
Okay. What uh am I missing something? Or have permission of a
parent or guardian. Yeah, the parents are probably like they
the kid could have easily just been like
couple things. One,
uh you still have a a requirement on your end to do something
if somebody gets in there who is under that age. Okay. First
and foremost,
you that's not a loophole. Oh, actually, you know, I just assumed
this 14-year-old was lying about their age because there's no
way somebody could have fooled the online system of Patreon into
letting them into my my Discord if they were under 18, right?
That's obviously
second,
um, you must be or have the permission. They could have easily
gotten permission from a parent or guardian without them being
fully aware of what your content is, right? And obviously, by
the way, Nucks would argue, isn't his content like making fun
of like, it's not actually in any way. It's just making fun of
that stuff, man. There's nothing. Your your content's totally
wholesome,
Uh, as we welcome people over the age of 13, we employ stricter
measures to ensure their safety that ultimately translates to
a zero policy for underage individuals on Patreon.
Well, that's true. I I was hoping it would be in the Discord
as well. I'm sure there's more stuff about how your Discord has
to be managed in here. Literally, that obviously didn't happen.
This was inherently an 18 plus Discord server. So, if someone
lied or stole their mom's credit card or their mom let their
kid join a Discord server from a guy that was making more um
you know, adult focused content on my YouTube channel. Uh that
is the parents fault. Okay, just to be clear again, I'm really
sorry if any bad thing happened to any person in in any of my
>> Oh,
that's rough. Holy xil, we're going to watch that in just a little
bit. servers. Obviously, that's horrible. However, it was an
18version,
>> are we hearing that the Nuaku channel,
YouTube, that in 2018 they actually weren't even a degenerate
channel that I believe that's in the calendar, right, of when
he started when he realized that like stuff was actually the
way to go, right? So, early on, he's actually just doing like
a lot of anime content. This is 2016, right? Get further into
2017, still just regular anime content. Regular anime content
that this kid signed up for, right?
This would be Is this 2017 or 2018 here?
>> It's still 2016 actually, but okay. Keep going back.
Still just anime content. Anime content. Anime content. Anime
content. I'm looking for anything that could be seen as DGEN
here. Anime content. Anime content. Anime content. not like explicitly
stuff. Yeah. So, there's the first thing that's like a little
and this is a trailer for an anime. So, that's the first thing
that's even remotely approaching what we talk about. Otherwise,
just totally
so easily they could have had permission from their parents to
be in this discord right here. This got to be 2018.
>> For many years, Code Gas was my favorite >> 2019.
So, yeah. Okay.
Damn. And so obviously parents would allow you their kids into
your Discord for sure. >> This not safe for work tab that
ended up this channel, this notsafe for work channel, which again
I regret. I don't think I should have ever done that. That was
definitely a mistake on my part. I'm not trying to say it wasn't.
But 2018, 8 years ago, I really, I guess, didn't think about
it clearly enough. This server was removed. This channel with
the not safe for work thing was removed really quickly um after
it was made, I think, if I remember correctly. Um and even more
Oh, is he mistaking it with his public Discord now? Because that
was his public Discord where after two weeks they got rid of
it, right?
It was his public Discord where they got rid of it super fast.
I think this not safe for work channel had to have stuck around
for a while.
I believe there's like references to it quite a bit later.
I don't know how long this one stuck around for. Maybe we'll
get the correction from Nickur, but I think his public Discord
was the one where they got rid of it fairly quickly. >> Importantly,
this also had an age verification.
Um, this also had an age verification. You needed to click that
you were 18 plus to join the this channel in the server. All
right. So, anywh who the point that I'm trying to make is um
yeah, I up by having a not safe for work server. I definitely
regret that. But, uh, yeah. All right. Calling me a for this
is insane levels of slander. Another thing important to note,
um, a lot of pe, >> and again, I think it's just everybody
else calling you a not
>> uh because it's an 18 plus situation. If you have a
Patreon, a lot of people actually put not uncensored on their
Patreon. All right, this is trash taste popular anime podcast.
All right, on their trash taste show. Get the Nobody's got a
problem with pat selling like um 18 plus content on Patreon,
bro. Nobody's got a problem with that. Literally, nobody actually
has a problem with that. Nobody's saying you're endangering kids.
The issue here is that you had a kid. You They literally said
they were a kid. Okay.
And you built the You made the NSFW channel for them. Now, he
might have done that before they admitted they were a kid because
it was like right when it was first made, right? But then you
had to have been aware over time. Oh. Uhoh. There's a person
in his chat, but not one of the good ones. One of the bad ones.
Looks like there's a person in his chat creating a ruckus.
Get him out. Get him out. Get him out of here. Get him out of
here. Oh boy. That's funny. >> Version of episode 25, the
episode and future uncensored episodes for $5 a month. All right.
And it's like,
>> yeah, cuz you know, Patreon is an uncensored
situation. Next to Kendra's video is going to go crazy, bro.
He is he is just like obviously lying this whole time.
It's so funny, man.
right? Like he is just clearly obviously lying about what's going
on here. Totally misrepresenting the criticisms, saying this
guy just called me a with no evidence. It's like no, that's not
even the chief criticism of the video. If it is made, if it's
made at all, I don't think it is. Right. The chief criticisms
are actually possibly
I'm not totally sure.
What's up, Alien Embryo? How's it going?
I I can't believe he came on stream to just lie to just openly
lie about what was going on >> where you have to be 18
to donate [__] All right. Um, also important to note,
unfortunately, and I regret this cuz I told you many times I
regretted making this kind of content. I've said this myself
a long time ago.
>> Uh, uh, actually PewDiePie made content like this. And
we don't call him a I actually think probably people would have
criticism for this. Yeah. Now, I'm not even gonna say that 10
years ago, which is two years before Knox did this, like I'm
not gonna say that this wasn't wrong, but there was a different
internet culture, right? The internet was in a very different
place 10 years ago, 2016. There was like a different internet
culture going on at the time, and there were bad things happening.
The issue with Nu is that like once you get into that Discord
with that kid, it's a provable it's a provably bad issue happening
right in front of your face,
right? like this is probably bad. This probably should never
have been allowed, but we know that now. Everyone did these videos.
All right, PewDiePie, biggest YouTuber on the platform at the
time, was making Bokun no Pico reaction. Boku No Pico is uh this
is probably four to five years before Nu even started doing this
kind of content. By the way, >> that I never reacted to
even though basically everyone else did. This unironically was
a huge meme that everyone was doing. This is an animation of
adults
little boys um quite literally and it became a huge meme
and a lot of massive YouTube channels ended up reacting to it
and talking about it. Um and I who definitely
>> this is way way before and trust me I'll I'll still
say it was bad for people to react to this and and like put eyes
on this but especially bad for PewDiePie, right? But it's one
video. It is by far not like the genre of his channel. It's not
something he engaged in a lot. Right.
Knucks basically built his channel around this kind of stuff
5 years later. >> He did criticize a lot of this that came
out of Japan. Um
unfort it's worse than that. Nux. Yeah, I know. It's it's worse.
It's a really disgusting thing. But unfortunately, it was really
common now. Oh god. Do we film Do we film on the Nuaku channel
for Boku Nico? Do you think Do you think he's signaling right
now? Nux Taku. Hold on. Noox Taku and
uh Nuxanor Aboku. No Pico. I actually this might not pop up.
[__] >> I find it ironic that people like Hassan.
All right. Hassan is going to show up and he's going to call
me a and call Tea and call everyone everything. Now Hassan
is calling me a for things he's done. All right. Like this dude
went on podcasts where they promote this kind of thing. All right.
People on this podcast are pro directly. Pro Lolli.
Oh. Does interacting with prolly people put you in a bad spot,
Nux? Uhoh. Uhoh.
Actually, Hassan hangs out with proy people, too. Oh, boy.
Um, Hassan is only friends with Connor. Connor pushed back on
his co-host for the lolly stuff. Oh, hold on. Son's only friends
with one of the guys. And apparently that guy doesn't like the
name into the lonely.
>> Oh, is this this is not the Connor eats pants guy, is
it? >> Uh, no. She Well, >> I mean, it depends. [laughter]
>> Well, this is the
No, officer. She's a
>> She's a drawing
>> sea dog. Right. Right. [laughter] Right. >> I
mean, if we I don't know if I want to open up that debate cuz
that debate is a landmine of uh takes. Yeah. But yeah, I mean
like >> we we can open that up. [laughter] >> I don't
I don't know if I want to, man. >> Cuz you'll GET A LITTLE
>> I'M IN THE WORST position for that.
>> I'm in the worst position for that >> Cuz you
know there's no no good defense for yourself. >> Oh, I
mean Yeah, but I also don't really care. [laughter]
>> You know, it's
Jesus. [laughter] >> You don't need It's like you don't
need a defense to be like, "Yes, this is my girlfriend. I don't
care what you think. I love her." I mean, I I I don't think it's
like a I'm not trying to There's the There people who are like,
"Yeah, it's p." I'm like, "I I don't know about that." But like,
I think there's going to be something a little sus about being
like, "Yeah, they're my wife."
>> I'm not going to willingly, you know,
>> Okay. I've heard of this guy before. I've seen content
from this guy before.
>> Um, I don't even know who this guy is. Anyway, what
is that? But Hassan went on this podcast one time and
and this guy likes openly pro Lolli. I however have really not
ever been proi to to be honest. I I really haven't. And if you
go to my old content, you will note that I have always I got
cancelled for being not pro Lolli enough. Not even kidding. All
right. Like they have figurines of
anime children on their broadcast. I can judge what the >> ladies
and gentlemen that I shout out
>> I do find it very funny that he's sitting here signaling
about Hassan.
I I don't know how people think they can get out of their problems
this way. like
over and over again.
If for no other reason you should get rid of the um the Hassan
is bad thing. If for no other reason than every weird
problematic person on the internet seems to use this as a way
to like get out of
I'm I'm sorry. I'm sorry. >> Just forgot.
Everybody round of applause.
Well done, Joey. Well done. I'm proud of you. Proud of you, Joey.
Are we going to prison? >> Even though I've I saw about
10 era manga for sensei figures along the way. >> Why is
there so many? >> I don't know. I don't know. It's popular
enough, I guess. Uh it's actually not too bad to be honest with
you. I'm not exactly a fan of uh Arama Sensei, but >> yeah.
So Aramonga Sensei, for those of you that are unaware, it's a
story about I think she's like an 11-year-old girl. It's really
funny. Also, Nux thinks it's like a life hack. It's like Yeah.
showing like children or having drawn images of kids. And that's
all fine as long as you like shake your head and say, "This is
very bad. I very much disavow this. This is very bad." You build
a whole content model on it where where a bunch of kids see this
content, right? I'm very bad. This is very bad, guys. This is
very, very bad. No, no, it's bad. No, actually, it's really bad
anime. I'm not going to. So, anyway, anyho, I find it hilarious
when Hassan [__] is going to show up and slander
the full context for when Hassan [__] paid for services
for multiple prostitutes at a German brothel sex trafficking.
Oh, this seems like a good source. Definitely. This guy definitely
least Israeli source he could find for Hassan hate. Least Israeli
source. Okay. I don't know if you guys have seen any of the other
stuff this guy's put in his Twitter. Okay. It's a little rough.
>> Yeah. Look, man. Look, glass houses and all that. Now,
Hassan, let's just say I always find it funny when he sits in
his glass house and he throws stones. So, this is Hassan supporting
Houthy terrorists.
You said Ethan's words can make him seem proinist and that he
should be more thoughtful. But when he pointed out that your
language can come off as supportive of terrorism, why not just
admit that you're careless sometimes too to his fans and made
you look like you can't admit fault? I have no problem with the
Houthies. Yeah, because I don't. What do you mean? If you think
I'm a terrorism supporter for that reason, then yeah, I'm a terrorism
supporter. What are you talking about? >> Right. So pro-
houthy terrorists. Now you probably think that well Assan doesn't
only he doesn't only love and support terrorist.
He also loves China. He cosplays as Mao. He soy faces whenever
he gets Mao's little red book. He is a massive Mau stand. All
right,
Okay, this part is totally true. I'm never going to defend Hassan
on the China stuff. He's way too into China. Don't care. Go back
to defending yourself on the Discord thing. Could you talk about
the 15-year-old who's groomed into dropping out of school? We
talk about glass houses.
>> I mean, yeah, communism isn't perfect, but under a dictatorship
of the proletariat, every single monster on the Epstein list
would have been shot. Oh, really? Oh, really? Stalin impregnated
a 13-year-old. Mao had a relationship with a 14-year-old. Castro
is literally in the Epstein files. All right. CCP maxing over
there. All of his favorite commie losers are also I just forget.
Were there any heads of state of Israel in those piles? I forget.
Could we could we find maybe a head of state from Israel in those
files or
>> So again, every single Hamas hero, every single Hassan
hero kids. So yeah, glass houses pretty insane. Now to be clear,
to be clear, I want to make this clear. >> Sorry, glass
houses. Who are they to criticize my of children when they do
it themselves? Who are they to question me and how I groom kids?
Thank you. Thank you. Um, very >> yeah, I do regret making
LWD content in the past. I grew, I've evolved, I've become a
much bigger person. I actually at the peak of my career when
I was uh making getting millions of views on my videos doing
that. I actually decided to walk away from it uh because, you
know, I wanted to do something better. I uh got more religious
actually over time and I decided to do something better with
my content and honestly really proud of where I came. So, I don't
actually owe anything to anybody, but um
there's just absolutely no way. Okay, this is the test. This
has to be the test, right, for Hassan's badism.
This is where the line is. If this guy can somehow cobble together
a career with Hassan is bad after what he's done,
actually just asteroid as soon as possible. Okay, there's no
possible way you could Hanis badge your way out of this. It's
not possible. It's not possible. It's It would be crazy.
this this dude. Holy [__] this guy is evil as But
anyway, thanks so much for being here. Appreciate you guys. Big
kisses to the people. Definitely subscribe. I'll see you in the
next one. Um and uh honestly,
don't watch. It's not good for you. It's not good for you.
There's no way he does the sign off for his little videos while
he's streaming, too.
Oh, boy.
You think Naku can Hassan as bad his way out of this one? No.
No. I'm saying this cannot be it. This cannot happen. This literally
can not happen. This is where the line is.
Like with all of the other stuff, it was bad. With this, it would
be like
I don't I don't know. Did Queen get banned from his chat? I don't
know. I'd have to ask him. I'm just saying this is where this
is where the line is. If if you can Hassan's badge your way out
of this, I lose it. I lose my mind. Okay. I I
All righty. Let me find this time stamp for Dicker's stream here
real quick and we'll watch some of the Nicandra's reaction.
So, about 30 minutes in. 30 minutes in
right here.
>> We were talking about the clip that he was about to
show uh from Shimu.
>> This is the most wild clip of the video.
>> Okay, let me seek through it. Try and find it. Oh,
Please upload ASAP
before this. Before this >> before this >> that is
that's also Yes. And that's also another thing. >> So the
clip cuts off before the age is specified. The clip cuts off
basically with with Shimu highlighting that this person lied
about their age and then it like cuts off without saying well
actually the lie was in the opposite direction. That the lie
makes it the truth makes it worse. The lie was The lie helps
you. >> He denies his content ever being harmful. Okay.
He denies his content ever having caused any harm to anybody
ever.
Like he's willing to make that extreme claim.
And however, he still decided to change his content because you
know what he says is that
to a lot of people this is like harmful or whatever on the internet
or something like that's that's the phrasing he uses like that
is the most clearest that that he has said or talked about that
uh the reason he's changes content is because to a lot of people
what he used to do is seen as harmful.
I do think that uh Naku was legitimately
like for a lot of other people they do give the cope to why they're
like moving over. I think Tech does it relatively successfully
even if people don't like Techone. He's talking about always
having these views, always having these beliefs. Uh Knox can't
totally advertise all all that same way. I do think if Knox was
like as open about his like conversion to Judaism and moving
to Israel and all this stuff, I really don't think people would
take him as seriously. I actually think he hides it for that
reason that like that would be the cope reason he gives, right?
I really don't think he would. I don't I don't think he could
be as obvious about >> His family are obviously conservative
in the military, but he hid them for a long time until Charlie
Kirk got shot. Like, it's not true. If you look in and go back
and take a look at what um what Teone said at the past, it's
not true. But you've got to do like a deep dive to be able to
know whether or not that's true. You know what I mean? With Noxaku
on its face, you can tell this is a lie cuz he's not even coming
up with a good sweep or like a good reason. I think he's seen
that he can just go in this content direction and he hasn't really
like took a second to think about how he's going to portray that
to his audience. I think I feel like at this point Nux was a
more obvious grifter than Techoners and Techoners
>> I think doesn't that work both ways? Doesn't that that
feels like it goes both ways, right? That like if you didn't
have
a solid direction that you like if you didn't have um a solid
narrative for why you changed, that might indicate that you just
haven't thought about needing to justify it, that the change
was just happening over time. Now, if you get asked about it
a lot, maybe.
But like to me, I don't I don't think that's dispositive. I don't
think it's like a hugely consequential that you can't explain
or give like a solid through line for why you changed.
>> Admitted it in court. You know what I mean? [laughter]
Also, thank you to Cold Heart for the 99 cent super sticker love
heart emoji. Thank you. And for the $5 as well. >> Knox
is Nux is definitely a grifter. Knox definitely saw the writing
on the wall with the conservative grift and went in that direction
100%.
>> Noob. Yes. Thank you. Thank you very >> Forced
any of the weird [__] that I would comment on. I
would make fun of it. All right. It was never an endorsement
at all. And these people are all liars and disingenuous. Now,
the new the new angle [laughter] that people are
>> Wait, hold on, dude. Okay, tell me if I'm wrong. Maybe
I've misunderstood part of your video or misremembered it. Okay.
Didn't Knox Taku celebrate
listings and
listings started to change because of the effects of his video?
>> How was that not [clears throat] an endorsement? If
I make a video about child, okay, and I'm condemning it
>> Uh, was that Oh, that was the time stopping one, right?
Did we get an age on the time stopping
like what the age of the the antagonist or what? Was that lolly
stuff? >> And then Google trends start to change where
people are searching up instances of child that I've talked about.
>> I guess it's downstream of that, right? That if you
gave recommendations for something and people and you saw trends
change, then you know you're having an effect. Therefore, pulling
up lolly in the future also bad. >> I'd probably think
about how good a good a job I've done making fun of it and condemning
it.
>> It's so
Yeah. And there's also the aspect that um um I haven't shown
these are for like the next video, but there's clips of Naku
talking about how he inspired other people, other anime YouTubers
into making this kind of content. He inspired the [laughter]
anime man, Heavenly Controller, and Gig, you know, and you know,
Joey the anime anime man and Gig are both, you know, people on
the trash taste podcast. So
>> oh wait, did he brag about inspiring Gigick and then
he uses Gig against Hassan? That would be especially deranged
of him. Oh, hold on. Does Does Neandress have this clip? I might
need this clip really badly. >> He is utterly screwed.
He's completely
on this like narrative that like it's it's another lie that he
tells that I'm going to debunk that like oh back in the day there
was this trend of just putting obscene stuff on thumbnails and
uh you know look at look at Joey the anime man um you know look
at his thumbnails from >> oh wait >> three years
ago and like you know they're not the same
>> Joey the anime is the other guy that's Joey that was
on there that was like the explicit the like the huge
>> that's back then >> and um >> you know cut
to a video from 2019 that's been deleted >> by the way
>> uh Naki video from 2019 he's just bragging like hey
yeah I got I got the anime man >> to do this kind of content
>> and uh yeah it's not it's not going to be pretty
>> oh man cuz I I've heard as well with Naku or I've seen
it actually you've got people with
drawn pictures of little girls as their profile pictures on Twitter
saying that Naku has finally got his comeuppants for betraying
the community. I mean, >> that's hilarious, dude. Yeah,
he that's what happens, man. You called us. Guess what? Now you're
a >> It seems like he's getting it from both sides. But
that's the problem when you lie about this stuff, right? You
try and paint yourself up as something you are. Your former fans
are going to feel betrayed and everybody else is going to feel
as though you're being disingenuous currently. You win with absolutely
>> Is that Wait, he could just genuinely
No, you can just genuinely change, right? It's just
uh how do you put it?
I could I I got the feeling the stuff was the the passion he
had. Okay. I was grooming people in a Discord. Uh, a lie. I've
never groomed anyone ever. Just repeat the pointroom anyone.
>> My video does not accuse Naku of grooming. It accuses
him of being a uh a bad moderator and basically allowing it to
happen.
>> I mean, early early introduction is a part of grooming,
I would say.
I I definitely think like but I think that's a good argument
you can make that early introduction is a facet of
Like like that would be a part of grooming somebody would be
showing them material, desensitizing them to this >> I
mean, I'm going to be honest. I'm going to be honest, right?
With just how defensive out of the gate that No Taku was being
about the allegation of Grooven. It's not looking good. It's
really not [__] looking good cuz he's got all of
these other cope and lies around it. Before watching this reaction,
I didn't think that he'd ever groomed anybody. That thought never
even entered into my mind. Now,
>> now I'm not so sure. I'm not as confident as I was before.
[laughter] >> It's like that bad of a response. You start
thinking about other allegations that he's not even accused of
>> whenever. All right. So, it's a lot of uh a lot of implications
that get thrown >> I mean,
no, no, no. The Discord was a little different, man. The Discord
is not the Chuck-E-Cheese.
the the Chucky dude. He ran like the the Amazon of EPI through
his YouTube channel. Okay, maybe you call it it's more boutique
in his Discord, okay? More boutique, more directed, more intentional,
but the the channel itself when you look at how many kids are
like and NARO shows it every single time. How many kids are just
asking for source in the comments?
very I do love his psychotic delivery, okay, where he's like,
and you know, maybe these people could be lying about their age,
but I checked every single one of their profiles and I know that
they are children. I have seen their shorts. They are children.
It's like, okay, I don't know why I did Russian for a Finnish
guy, but >> it works. This is the most viral clip of the
video. >> No implication made in the video about Naku grooming
anybody. I mention in the video that uh I pull up the log of
like uh someone saying is Knoxaku grooming Allen and I debunk
that. No, that's not happening. That's a joke. I defend Naku
from implications of him being a groomer in the video and he's
now [clears throat] saying that I am implying he's a groomer.
That's amazing. You also shield you also shield yourself from
that really [__] well where in where in the start
I was criticizing you going into the video for [__]
sweeping for Nu and Mutah but you like it's a it's a total like
it's like I don't know like sugar to help the medicine go down.
You sort it out. >> It's it's that he's basically wait
it's that he's basically lying isn't it that he's like I would
never say that with no evidence and then he slowly unveils or
unveils the evidence as he goes along. right? He's like, I would
never accuse them of doing this intentionally. And then he slowly
unveils it over time that like, oh, they are very aware of like
the problems. They are very aware of a lot of the things going
on. Maybe not Mudahar, but Nux is for sure. >> Without
being insanely fair to N. So, I feel that this just like falls
on deaf >> Unveils, reveals, unveils. Yeah, my bad, man.
I mix I mix words sometimes. Okay. >> Completely falls
flat. >> It happens
>> With the most serious allegation that I saw. So, um,
let's, uh, let's watch this clip. I'll play the clip and I'll
give you my commentary. >> The NSFW channel wasn't there
from the start. We can trace its creation to this exchange from
October 15th, 2018, where we can see this user who from
>> sell was there.
>> I put you later in the video. Yeah. >> Now on
will be called red repeatedly asking KN to create it. If we look
at the time and date of these messages, >> for the record,
um, this Discord server was made in 2018. It was a Patreon only
Discord server. All right, it was not a public Discord server.
It was
evergreen side quest excerpt from the trash taste where they
are reviewing Little Devil Girlfriend. Oh man, do I want to click
on this? Do I want to click on this? Yeah. Podcast not >> What's
the next one?
>> Next one. >> Little Devil Girl. I guess >> we
can talk about Little Devil Girl. Yeah, we can we can uh >> little
devil girlfriend. >> So fantastic animation. >> Oh,
amazing animation.
>> I was not really
>> really a fan of the art style. >> They are. Yeah,
they we watch your suggestions and regret it. They're just doing
the next content. For sure. For sure. For sure. Now, I guess
you'd have to look at what the thumbnail is for this because
that's a part of it, right? And you'd have to look at another
thing that could be done here is how monetized is this? Is it
18 plus content that they did as a joke? I think most of the
criticisms go away if you mark this content accurately,
right? Like if you just have this content marked as 18 plus and
you do this content, nobody has a problem with it. Like we're
not saying has to be taken off of the internet. Nobody's saying
that. Okay.
This series they've done four times. The uncensored version is
on their Patreon. Okay. I I feel like the censorship on this
stuff doesn't necessarily work if it's still overtly the whole
time. You know what I'm saying? Oh god. Oh god. Hold on. >> Vanilla.
Vanilla.
>> Yeah. I I I could just tell
this one was going to be bad. Oh Jesus. Yeah. There's more stuff
in here. Gh.
>> Patreon only. All right. Anyway, for for don donors.
Oh, and by the way, I have a Patreon link in the description.
SUPPORT MY WORK. OH, THAT WOULD BE REALLY GREAT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
SO, the reason why the raids were happening on the Discord server
is because KN did not set the roles, the permissions for the
new channels that he made properly, which allowed people to generate
invite links into the Discord server, which allowed like these
spam accounts to come in or people to like use their alts to
like come in and spam gore. like it's like his own moderators
talk about it in the server as like and when they one of the
problems is they're like oh we have mod powers now but we don't
have channel management powers so we can't fix this issue >> there
are logs of this them talking about this so the idea that oh
uh kids can't get in or like a child could not possibly get in
is ridiculous
or like in so many grounds even if you accept the
>> it's it doesn't matter because it happened and then
they were informed that it happened and nobody was >> like
oh um the the toos like will prevent the child from >> Hold
on another
you forgot to pause TTS wonder what it fun >> how old are
you really >> okay from I I have no doubt that you can
figure out this giga guy and the joey guy that they're like gay
that they do this kind of [__] all the time I don't
want I don't want all the clips of those >> or something
like that >> I'm not >> not interested in those people
okay >> yeah I Maybe for another day. >> That argument
just never flies. It never flies. Especially when this guy is
saying in the Discord server, I am 14. Like every time Naku says
that just like all you need to do is throw up the screenshot
of them saying that they're 14 and every other time that people
around them confirm that this person is underage, it just cut
it. Yeah. >> Also, yo, thank you Dan Mac Photography for
the five. I just tried to send a super for 5 minutes. I cannot
figure out what word was flagged beside dickers with the R
148 live before bot attack.
Israel flag emoji. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Um I don't
know. I'm not sure. Probably not. Probably not. We'll see. Appreciate
it. All right. But anyway, so yeah, continue. >> W channel
was made 2 minutes later. >> There is a note here saying
absolutely nothing from miners by the way. No personal nudes,
no content of miners. By the way, that node was added at a much
later date from the, you know, the creation of the channel.
>> Oh boy. >> Wait, really? How do you know that?
>> We keep going >> cuz it's in the logs. It's in
the It's in the logs. Um, I did not show them in my video yet,
but uh in the video, but um there's also
quite a bit of like
on that channel of a Gojo from Hunter
>> and uh you know,
it's not like uh it's [laughter] not like those rules were always
followed.
>> Is that the little lad with the green hair? Yeah, if
you don't know who that is, I haven't seen the anime myself,
but he's the guy who he's from the meme where it's like Goon,
I love Israel, goon, I love Israel, is real. You know that meme?
>> Yeah, right. >> Yes, that kid there.
>> The one that Tiger was into, by the way.
>> Totally random connection, but uh >> Yeah. Also,
wait. Oh, that's interesting as well cuz he says that allowed
depictions of fictional characters, they could be reasonably
interpreted as being 18 plus.
Wait, what?
>> So, they're saying,
>> they're saying no.
And so, I don't know if Nicandra is saying I don't know if he
he must know that it got added later, but regardless of whether
it was added later or not, there's a ton of that totally like
doesn't follow this rule at all.
Loophole. No, it's not a loophole. It's not it's not even that
they're loopholeing here at all. Um he's saying that basically
even if that rule applied, there's a whole bunch of of clearly
underage characters there. So it doesn't like they weren't applying
the rule anyway. So the rule is just like >> You're saying
now so you're not even allowed to post lolly in this. But this
content of Gohan
>> or whatever the [__] this guy name is
that guy. >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Right. I get you now. I
understand. >> None of that. All right. Just just to be
>> in response to this, Red raised their Patreon pledge.
>> Wait, wait. None of no part of that said no kids themselves.
>> Gave them a thumbs up. >> For a brief moment,
let me take you to August of >> This is the guy that made
the video. If you want to watch [clears throat] the full video,
you should go watch it. By the way, if you want if you want to
watch an hour and a half of this name calling me a um with zero
evidence that >> I didn't call you a pedoph.
[laughter]
I was Yeah, that seems like pretty obvious to me, right? The
bear avatar is appropriate for Nick Andros. Yeah. What did Nicandro
say? He's like 66 or something as well. He said 203 cm or something.
Yeah. He's got to be a big guy, dude.
>> by the way, if you want if you want to watch an hour
and a half of this, >> the cope here from Knox is crazy.
This guy just calls me a with no evidence at >> Say my
name
with zero evidence. pull your head up a single time. [laughter]
>> You weasel.
>> Dude, at least this is a keto screenshot. You've literally
got his little cartoon character freaking the out about your
name being on screen. >> Pledge and not escape. >> This
has got to be the intro for the next video. >> Thumbs up.
>> For a brief moment, let me take you to August of >> This
is the guy that made the video. If you want to watch the Wait,
that is actually funny. The double take.
Do you see the double take that the cartoon
>> This has got to be the intro for the next video. >> Thumbs
up. >> For a brief moment, let me take you to August of
>> Dude, the double take from the cartoon. So funny. Like
I don't think that's Could you even code that into the VTuber
to track that? Or is that just luck that that happened?
I don't even I don't know. Like maybe his head could be there
a little bit.
Now about your name being on screen.
This has got to be the intro for the next video. >> All right,
for >> watch watch the the double take on the eyes. Okay,
are the eyes not tracked? They would be tracked, but would it
be tracked to that part of the screen?
>> Cuz otherwise you'd be looking left a >> Brief
moment. Let me take you to August >> the guy that made
the video. If you want to watch the full video, you should go
watch it, by the way, if you want if you want to watch an hour
and a half of this guy um calling me a um with zero evidence
that I'm a you can watch this video. Um that would be great.
Um go do that. All right. Hey, I'm not not trying to hide his
eyes moving, bro. >> Stammering,
stuttering,
eyes dotted.
>> I showed the guy's name.
>> To be clear, go ahead and watch the video. It's totally
not incredibly
>> All right. Not not putting it under the rug at all.
Absolutely. If you want to >> Dude, he sounds so bad. I
>> watch it. Go watch it. I will not be four hours reacting
to an hour. >> Next Doc is going to be uh gaping and shaking.
Jes, stop talking about this poor man. Jesus Christ. [laughter]
>> You're saying that he's polo and you're
>> What's the Cinderella?
>> Just gigabytes and gigabytes of >> He's going
to be gaping and shaking.
>> Hour and a half long video calling me a >> nothing.
Nothing. >> Again and again and again for things I've already
addressed.
you have not addressed a lot of these things, buddy. [laughter]
How has he what what what has he addressed before the thumbnails?
I guess he's vaguely >> he's addressed the early introduction
stuff because he's done that PewDiePie cope about the thumbnails.
He's vaguely talked about, you know, content. He hasn't talked
about anything about like his Reddit. He hasn't talked about
anything about his comments. Like
it's uh yeah it like [clears throat] this guy is completely and
utterly done >> especially given the fact I mean keep on
saying it again and again and again but like everything that
he says about this he has not watched the video. He's got no
idea what he has and hasn't responded
>> I feel like with this it's such like a weak response.
He's I
I disagree. I'm sorry. I think he
I personally think he's watched the video. He has at least a
good idea of everything that's in the video and that there just
is no response. Like there is no response. Shot like it's over.
All your only option here. It's because if there was some way
to respond, I think he would respond. There's just no way to
respond. It's like it's just catastrophic for him. He He has
no response. He just has to lie. That's his only option is to
He's going to get this like slapped in his face probably for
like I don't know 6 months, 12 months, something like that if
not into, you know, into perpetuity because he's just like this
response is >> about his past content and he was >> So
to be clear, this is also incorrect. This is not when I was being
pressed for my past content. This was literally a video. I I
actually think it's like incumbent on people. Do I want to straight
up advocate
brigading? I don't know. Hold on. cuz he said we're going to
put a video out on this. So, did he put one of the videos out
on this? I don't see the video today. He said the video is here
for today, but it's not. Oh, wait.
Hold on. Did it, guys? He told his editor, right? He messaged
his editor. There's the second video. Go ahead. There's a second
video. Put it up. Did he not do the whole thing or is it Wait,
is it right at the Is it right at the end of this?
>> Oh, it's right at the end of this. It's embedded at
the end of this. It backfired. He found out he buried it in the
back of a video like the cowardly rat he is. Buries in the back
of a Hassan is bad video. Merges it together with more Hassan
is bad content.
Yeah, that [__] ain't going to work. Little bro,
that [__] ain't going to work, Lil Bro.
I think it's incumbent on you to to actually say, "Hey, you you
didn't actually respond to anything in the video." I'm going
to put this in the uh Yeah, you you
little brat. It's It's crazy that this loser is trying to hide
this response. He's He's trying to say, you know why he does
this, right? So that if people say, "Oh, you didn't respond."
He'll be like, "No, I put a video out on it." "No, I put a video
out. I put a video out on it." You can't you can't call me like
you you can't say I was hiding from it. Can't say I didn't respond.
I totally responded.
I totally responded, man. Disgusting. Actually disgusting. that
I made talking about my 10 years on YouTube cuz it was like my
10 year YouTube anniversary. All right. This was not like a response
video as far as lying. The >> the Murahar confrontation
happened before this buddy. You were talking about the old thumbnails
in this >> for that exact reason.
>> Oh, cuz this was the criticism from you. I guess Chud
echoed it. Mutahar decided to drop him for it and did post. >> Is
he just lying here? >> Right. Well, how long after the
postnux clarity happened after this? Okay. >> Oh, okay.
>> That's December 2024.
Um, the mutard dropping KN thing happened, you know, before this
and he was supposed to be on a live stream to be confronted by
harmful opinions of myself if he wanted to get back on the someordinary
podcast. That's the big that's the big juicy reveal of this that
he's been running away from me for uh 2 years or whatever.
But um [clears throat] the thing is right
that uh instead of doing a live confrontation because he knows
he would lose, he did this indirect response instead. >> And
uh yeah, he's he's just being a lying [__] now,
>> That's crazy. >> Maybe I'm mistaken. I'm thinking
of the wrong video, but >> we're stealing this for a second.
I'm getting some screenshots to show this real quick. >> That's
what I thought. >> Pushed into making a response. The biggest
shock to me to this day entering the broader commentary sphere
was the dangers lurking around every corner in regards to children.
Children are not safe on the internet. I only became chronically
online after high school, but I couldn't imagine what it would
do to me if I was in some YouTubers's Discord server at the age
of 12 or 14. Yeah. So, um, as you could see, I addressed many
times that I uh that I regretted the fact that I would make lewd
content and back in the day. Uh to be honest, I've mentioned
that multiple times. Literally called it out in the past. Uh
but anywh who, moving on. Uh this video
>> called it out. I'm guessing he's not talking about calling
himself out. Is he referencing the over Chris Tyson stuff? He's
called other people out for it. >> Or maybe he's calling
out the uh
>> or maybe he's calling out the uh the Twitch streamers,
you know?
>> Oh, is that what he's referencing? who that is incredibly
[__] weak.
>> He was he was putting lolly content on YouTube in 2022
still >> at the same time at the same time that he was
doing his thumbnails, right?
>> No, like that's a year after the he starts doing the
the uh the complaining about Twitch women. >> Wait, wait,
wait. So he I didn't Okay, so it's even worse than that. He starts
complaining about Twitch. >> Did you not [__]
watch my video, bro? I say clearly [laughter]
to an hour and 20.
>> Do you even pay attention loser? >> Long. If I'm
mistaken little bits here and there, I apologize. >> In
early 2021, he starts complaining about the Twitch women for
the first time. In February 2021, on his birthday, he released
the Twitch song. Okay. and uh he's still putting lolly, you know,
into his thumbnails in January of 2022.
>> He has no excuse for that behavior. >> Like he's
already saying like, "Oh, oh, this is inappropriate to be shown
to >> And it's like, >> "Okay, I've got the law.
>> I've got the law." Right. So, he criticizes it and then
engages it in himself. And now he's trying to do a return to
the first position that he had before he did the law thumbnails.
Right. Right. Right. Right. Right. >> Uh it was like a
10-year anniversary. This was not like some apology whatever.
Any uh partial response to criticism?
>> I don't know why after 10 years on YouTube usually that's
like a celebration. I think for most creators you usually celebrate
being a creator for that long. You wouldn't need to go live,
post a video, and talk about children can be at risk online.
Okay. I've come to realize that the children could be at danger
from predators online. Huh? What the have you done?
>> You couldn't imagine. You don't need to. All right.
>> Red joined the server on September 7th.
>> I just love how like he responds to me saying like,
"You don't need to in the video." Be like, "Okay, >> dude.
It's right there. It's right
>> Hold on.
>> No, no, no, no, no. They're gonna They're about to discover
why the clip is so good.
>> Red joined the server on Sep. >> You couldn't
imagine. You don't need to. All right, Red.
[laughter] >> Okay, I get what you're [__]
saying
>> Oh, yeah. Cuz he pauses it there. He pauses it there.
When Nux is saying, "I couldn't imagine being a 12-year-old,
13-year-old in a Discord server." And he pauses there and cuts
off the point before he then before you then segue.
Dude, I don't know. I don't want to get too skitso brain with
it.
>> I think I will say that. >> Joined the server
on September 7th. On day one, they openly declared themselves
to be 14 years old. >> I didn't know about this. >> They
would later claim to be 15 multiple >> So, I can go on
a server right now.
I can go on a server right now. And uh hold on a second. Let
me just do this. >> Wait. I I will say, okay, I will say
that as he is sitting here doing this response, I believe him.
I believe him when he says that he's got no idea about this because
earlier he's saying that a minor apparently snuck into my 18
plus Discord. They lied about their rage to get in. So, I think
that he's come out with the initial lie cuz he doesn't think
that you've got proof. >> So, hold on a second. Hold on
a second. >> You can't tell what Nanos's laugh is. I actually
don't know off the top of my head. Sorry, I'm trying to get >> the
worst [__] responses. This is going to be one of
the worst responses to a controversy like this in a while. Like
this is always the thing with drama, right? If you have like
a bad breakup, if you cheat on somebody if you give like an offcolor
take that might that might like uh you might be mocked for that,
right? And the drama might last like I don't know a couple weeks,
but really that's like incredibly small potatoes.
having the allegation that you are allowing the grooming of children,
facilitating it, encouraging it. You've seen the warning signs
and you do
>> Dude, this is
I'm shocked that he's not being more serious about it. >> That
is how close
Yeah, side chat. That's [laughter] how close Naku's
>> is to the uh the admission,
>> just to be clear. God.
So, there's Knucks, somebody somebody
else, and then down. Ooh, someone joined VC. Yes. Yes. Hell no.
I'm like 14. Me. Wait. So,
>> hang out there. >> Is that talking about people
in VC hanging out? >> I'm not sure. >> Difficult
to say without >> He's talking about He's talking about
um the Soy Boy person. Uh Soy Boy Theory streamed on your channel
yesterday. hangouts is what he said and two minutes later like
uh Red um drops the news that he's 14.
>> But it's not just this, right? People are constantly
referencing referencing this stuff back and forth. I mean, there's
a reason why you took like an entire video to kind of explain
this stuff, right? But you've got people saying that he doesn't
know and can't understand toys and so people have made a PowerPoint
to explain them to him.
Like the red blanks are all over. The idea that nobody's got
any clue this person's underage, it's unbelievable.
>> On September 7th, >> on day one, they openly declared
themselves to be 14 years old. >> I didn't know about this.
>> Oh my god, I know why you're picking it up now. Cuz
just at the top of that screenshot, out of out of eyesot is
>> Did you Did you crop it intentionally?
Okay. Okay. I don't know if you've got like a
>> little up. >> Listen, the fate. All right. I'm
guided by faith to destroy next. Okay. I don't need to think
about these things
>> They just happen. >> Divine [clears throat] blessing.
>> They would later claim to be 15 multiple times. But
as again the problem, so the problem with him saying, "I didn't
know about this. You were in voice chats with them. You were
in voice chats with this person and they are 14 years old and
you don't you don't recognize
[laughter] that they were that they're a minor. How how is this
possible?
Like a 14-year-old there's no way, right? Like I could maybe
understand
if if this guy if this kid was like 17 16 17 maybe a 14-year-old
man
there's just no there's no shot.
Oh, and by the way they would like they would like
oh they would like not squeal. I'm trying to think of a different
they would just be like gleeful when Nux was in. They would let
everybody know Nux is in the VC. They'd see Nux in the VC. They'd
let everybody know oh my god Nux is in the VC. Let's join.
There's no way this guy didn't know that this person was underage.
>> Yeah, I said this while I was reacting to it as well.
Like it's not people focus on like the squeaky voice too much.
Like people can have different intonations in their voice. I
think you pointed out Parlo sounds 12, but you'd still check
in, right? Especially not only with the squeaky voice, but talking
>> especially again, especially if he's saying if he's
saying that this is supposed to be an 18 plus, 18year-olds only
server, >> then that means that literally everyone who
knew about Red being a minor is like they're not reporting it.
Why is that why is that happening? Why not?
>> if there's the understanding the Discord server is 18
plus Yeah. >> Yeah. Then why why did no one report
>> But I I just don't believe that Naku didn't know at
the time. It's like he's talking about going to school. He's
talking about his school life and his school friends. >> What's
he talking about in VC? Like there's an obvious level of immaturity
that come through, right? Especially at >> I mean I don't
know how much the guy was talking about school outside of dropping
out. Sounds like he didn't like the place very much. >> He's
so stupid, dude.
>> Didn't they realize like how bad the the Shimu clip
makes it quite difficult to follow? From just the clip, you could
have this impression, right? From just the clip, you could have
this >> He's such a [__] [__] He
does not Yeah. He's saying openly, I'm 15, but he's lying about
being 15. He's actually 14. He's not lying about being 18. This
guy is such an embarrassing [__] dude. >> He's
trying to latch on to anything about this. >> Multiple
times, but as they >> I didn't know about this. >> Openly
stated they were lying about their age. Red was so Wait, hold
on. What was that screenshot there? Sorry, it's going back. >> They
would later claim to be 15 multiple times, but as they >> I
didn't know about this. >> Oh, until I tell you my actual
age, I'm going to say I'm 15. So, they intimate. They literally
say I'm lying about my age. I'm younger than I am.
>> Holy [__] Holy [__] >> And
somebody's
somebody's claiming he's actually 11.
>> Oh, right. I get you. Right, right, right, right, right.
Dude, what a [__] >> Openly stated. >> Worst
thing is, Worst thing is is he's frontloaded this. He's clearly
watched this video. This is the only thing that he's going to
look at. >> They were lying about their age.
>> Red was a prepared response. >> Born in 2000.
>> Oh, well, that's what I said. Okay.
>> Look, man, I don't know how a minor even got into this
Discord server because as I'm sure he mentioned this in the longer
video. I'm not trying to say that he tried to slander me on purpose
over here. Um, but this was a Patreon server. For those of you
that are unaware, Patreon servers are inherently 18 plus because
uh if you want to become a pat if you want to join a creator's
membership as a patron um or provide membership as a creator,
you must be at least 18 years old or have permission from a parent
or guardian. All right, this is where the uh so we some people
had watched a little bit of this before they saw us starting
to watch this this right. So they let me know that Ara was going
to pick out. Well, actually, technically, when you made this
Discord and this kid joined,
his parents would have seen Nux Nux's channel from 2018. There
was no content. It was all anime content in 2018.
His parents could even easily have consented. He He didn't have
DJ content until like 2021.
He was years away from making that kind of degenerate content,
>> quite literally. >> So, you can find the same
thing. You can find the same thing from uh You can find the same
thing on YouTube.
>> Yeah. You can find the same thing on YouTube where it
says like anyone who's like 13 or 14, you need to have parents
permission to like watch content on YouTube, but 13 and 14 year
olds still watch content on YouTube. Why isn't your defense for
the to say, "Oh, well, you know, uh it's the parents fault."
Why isn't that your defense? I think that I think that's Nick
Andress's normal speaking voice to be honest with you. I don't
think it's made up with him. How do I put it? I don't even know.
Could I get my voice that deep if I wanted to talk that way?
>> It's like bassy in a way. Yeah. I it feels like >> why
why are you objecting >> to like using this argument here
but not for the content overall
>> when you have the same argue that case >> especially
given the fact the second line of this that he doesn't read out
is as we welcome people over the age of 13.
We welcome people over the age of 13. The idea [clears throat]
>> tall people often have deep voices.
Forcing it removes the raspiness. If it's natural, it keeps the
raspiness.
Uh, no. I don't know about that. I
He's got Could I feel like I could get the raspiness in if I
if I took a minute? I feel like I could get the raspiness in.
>> That a parent has to be monitoring all the stuff that
this person gets access to. that's not even laid out in the to
all you need is initial uh permission from your parent or guardian
which is presumably a tick box right to be able to get onto it
>> that obviously didn't happen this >> like they've
got no idea if >> I mean also kids literally just lie on
the internet all the time >> and if you know that there's
a kid there it's like obviously the bad thing yeah >> obviously
a really bad thing >> everyone on this server knew that
Red was a minor and yet no one said like, "Hey, let's ban this
person." You're you're literally painting everyone on the server
as being like a predator or like being a
>> for not outing Red >> to start >> more realistically,
right? Cuz it's not that they're not outing him, they're constantly
making jokes about how young he is, right? You've got several
instances of them joking about how young this guy is. This never
came up in VC. This was never mentioned. Noox Taku never saw
any of those messages. Really? Really? Also, this is ignoring
the fact that Noox Taku is the owner and
>> I would want to know and I feel like my guess would
be the answer was no. I hope Nick Andrew asked this question,
but like did do you recall to this red person, do you recall
if Nucks ever made reference to your age or if he explicitly
pointed out how young you were in a VC before?
I gotta imagine the answer was I don't remember or no because
obviously I think it's obvious Nicandra would have asked that
question but maybe not. Sometimes he just missed obvious stuff.
So I got to imagine he just doesn't know but man >> is
of the server. It's not other >> I would want to know if
Nick Dickandra asked that question to be honest with
>> Yes. And he's getting paid for running it as well. If
this guy hasn't hired moderators for the server, that's ultimately
still his. >> I think Red said Nucks never explicitly never
explicitly acknowledged his age. Oh, I was thinking in text,
but sure. Maybe um maybe that was a blanket question he asked.
I do know that he followed up and showed some more logs of him
interacting with that person, like talking to them.
Yeah, it's just so weak source that he's trying to paint out
that this is impossible that you could ever imagine that somebody
under the age of 18 is going to like pay on Patreon because there's
an age restriction where they have to ask for permission
for the initial payment. >> It's like when you sign up
when you sign up on Club Penguin, you have to tell you have to
add your parents' email address. Okay?
You [snorts] have to add you have to add your parents email address
first to be able to sign up on Club Penguin. So therefore, no
child can ever create their own Club Penguin account. No child
would ever sign up for an email service. >> That's true.
That's true. With that very very slim provisor, technically Club
Penguin has got higher age restrictions than Patreon. >> Yeah.
Server from a guy that was making more um you know adult focused
content on my YouTube channel. Uh, that is the parents fault.
Okay, >> go back a little bit so we hear the full
>> Let's hear the full cope. Let's get it all. Yeah, >> that
obviously didn't happen. This was inherently an 18 plus Discord
server. So, if someone lied or stole their mom's credit card
or their mom let their kid join a Discord server from a guy that
was
can't get over how bad of a response to this this is. Wait, Kilo,
were you here when I just went over like how he put this up on
his website or on his YouTube channel? because he put this in
a YouTube video. Oh, yeah. You were here, right? No, you weren't
here. Wait, were you here? Did you see it yet? Did you see the
tweet? Because I do want to just show it again that if you go
to like Nuxenor, okay, you know. Oh, you missed it. Well, you're
going to have to go to my Twitter as well. It's literally 21
minutes into a 37 minute Hassan is bad video.
It backfired. He found out left his streamer going to jail. It's
He does a whole bunch of stuff on Hassan.
It's all of his Hassan stuff and then it's at 21 minutes he pulls
up the tweet. It's literally 21 minutes into a Hassan is bad
video. This guy is like the biggest rat on planet Earth.
Actual biggest rat on planet Earth.
Nuts. It's nuts, man. And by the way, yeah, it does appear to
have worked on his audience, right? Listening to leftists call
normal Americans fascist is next level insanity. I'm as shocked
as his dog. Hamas Pike will never lear and recover from Dogtober
7th. Socially crucified by the very mob he aimed to please. That
woman Hassan is talking to is absolutely heinous. I don't know
who needs to read this, but no communist will ever be communist
enough to be safe from communists. You'll be held to higher and
higher standard. Dog shocker.
Hassan isn't left or right. He's just
A codle child grows up being a crippled child. They always eat
their own. Both metaphorically and unfortunately literally. The
left eat their own. It's why people protect It's why they protect
people who eat babies. They're eating a lot more of their own.
He failed the purity spiral. Imagine how much they hate the average
fence sitter.
Bro, is there a single person looking at the time stamp like
after the the stuff? He actually said your name
and Nooku.
>> I mean, Ethan Klein's former account was literally called
on. It's absolutely wild.
>> Asan is bad. Asan is bad. Asan is bad. Asan is bad.
Asan is bad. Asan is bad. Was Ethan. >> Anyway, anyway,
we're back to not this one, but the YouTube video >> making
more um you know, adult focused content on my YouTube channel.
Uh that is the parents fault.
>> Stop. So Naku did not start the content, you know, pivot
until
August or September of 2019.
>> This happened in 2018.
>> Okay. 2019. Oh,
he must have removed a lot of the old videos then. When we went
and looked, it was like it was we're getting to like 2020 and
there still wasn't like a lot of stuff, right? We tried to go
back and look through some of his old
you
this >> Red joined the server in September 2018.
That is before the pivot into content. Okay.
At this point in time, he is only doing he's only doing anime
reviews. >> Wait, really? So, he hasn't even started doing
the thumbnails. That's in 2020.
started doing the >> permission could have easily been
signed >> continues until 2022, but it starts in 2019 when
he does that initial series of like you know biggest plot >> uh
I I believe I believe Nandros might have dropped on his birthday.
No, like the day after his birthday. His birthday is like the
first is like the second week of February or some [__]
Hold on. Nux Taku age.
He uh yeah, February 9th. He dropped like on the guy's birthday.
Okay. It wasn't enough. Or maybe the day after his birthday.
It wasn't enough to with the guy a little bit. Okay.
He like had to do it to him. It's so messed up, man. It's so
messed up, dog.
Couldn't even let the guy enjoy his like his 30th. Okay.
>> Videos. That's when the >> Yeah, he says it in
the video. That's the funny thing. I know you're 30 now, Nux.
Happy birthday. >> Content starts. He got massively a massive
amount of attention from that. At the time, he was only doing
uh anime reviews and some videos had like, you know, tumb,
>> you know, they were not reviews, dude.
>> Well, still, I mean, the exact same argument applies
to um to the um Ava Chris Tyson example, right? like they had
an NSFW channel in there. I believe it was age restricted the
NSFW channel, right? That's like in in line with Discord to the
exact same argument applies. The idea that a parent would have
no idea what a kid is doing online and so ultimately it's their
fault. It's not true. You moderate a Discord, you run a Discord,
>> you've accepted a level of agency over that or you just
you have to accept a level of agency over that or accept the
kids are going to get you've got those two choices, you know.
Yeah.
>> Okay. Just to be clear again, I'm really sorry if any
bad thing happened to any person in in any of my servers. Obviously,
that's disgusting and horrible. Uh, however, it was >> Sorry,
the silence just being >> 18 plus server. That's one. And
two, uh, also important to mention this not safe for work tab
that >> Yeah. When were the rules created? Do you have
a screenshot of that? >> They were made like the earliest
rules to my knowledge are from like 2020.
>> Years after the server was created.
>> I'll leave.
>> This channel is not safe for work
>> Let him let him out. >> Which again I regret.
I don't think I should have ever done that. That was definitely
a mistake on my part. I'm not trying to say it wasn't. But 2018,
8 years ago, I really, I guess, didn't think about it clearly
enough. This server was removed. This channel with the not safe
for work thing was removed really quickly um after it was made.
>> That was in his main Discord. >> I think so. This
is he just mixing up. >> This guy's >> That's his
That's his normal server, >> Yeah, that's a public server.
>> He's completely He's completely like He doesn't even
know the timelines here. >> Can't believe Nux responded
to the video in a totally fake and disingenuous way. He technically,
I suppose, responded to the video in a totally fake and disingenuous
way. Yes. >> Completely conflating things right now.
>> But even the idea that Nux would have never designed
a server if it wasn't 18 plus isn't true either. cuz when he
initially opened that server that he's talking about there, his
main public server, it it's not it's it's not true at all. It's
not true at all that he wouldn't have it unless it was 18 plus
cuz he had it initially at 16 plus, right? Nobody Nobody under
the age of 16, please. I believe is exactly what he said when
he announced it.
>> Oh man. >> And even more importantly,
this also had an age verification.
Um, this also had an age verification. and you needed to
>> So, you responded to a clip that Shimu did
responded to a clip. He didn't watch the Oh, sorry. He I think
he watched the full video, but he hasn't watched the full video
anywhere on a stream and he didn't respond to the most damning
allegations. He basically just lied about what the allegations
were. Like, he just lied the whole time he was responding.
And then he took that lying response and buried it within a YouTube
video that he published about Hassan >> like that you were
18 plus to join the this channel in the server. All right. >> Oh,
but he's talking about Wait, is it still not it's not age restricted?
No, I mean like it it does have the to discord like a NSFW channel
like tick but uh there is no you don't have to click on anything
to join that like channel on the even today even now
>> but he might be he might be mixing up the public and
private discord I'm not sure if how they did that in the public
discord when the NSFW channel was there but uh >> it's
like [clears throat] Even even it doesn't really matter, >> right?
At the end of the day, right? Because if you had an adult who
was sending a child links to,
we would still call that grooming. Whether or not the child had
to click yes, I'm 18 when they went on to actually see the right.
You get what I'm saying? >> We would still call that grooming.
>> We would still call that grooming. >> At this
point, I don't know how anybody could be blamed for grooming
ever online because it should be the parents responsibility is
the argument. Again, it's the thing that I've been that on Twitter
are coming at me we at me with and I'm asking them, okay, do
you think it's the parents fault if their child gets groomed
online? And they will bite the bullet and say, "Yes, it is mostly
I mean it regardless it doesn't matter, right? It literally
like okay, you could even say that it is mostly the kids like
this kid's parents, they probably should have been more involved.
It actually does probably mostly follow fall on
It also falls on you. I don't know them. I know you. I know that
this was incredibly irresponsible behavior. I can judge this
behavior in a vacuum regardless of what share the parents uh
have in the overall fault for them getting groomed by this guy.
Parents didn't know the exact situation. You had a good idea
of who this guy was. You shouted this guy out, right? The Allen,
whatever his name is, right? You you were shouting him out. you
had a good idea of who he was and you were at least to some extent
going to be aware of this kid's age for sure. >> And [laughter]
you know what can I say about these
>> I mean you even even accept in the video that it's a
shared responsibility, right? It's not 100% up to the content
creator. It's the platform, the person who owns the Discord and
the uh the parent as well. they've got to share. >> Every
every person in that situation has their own role. Okay. Like
as the platform, you have to reinforce the rules that 18 plus
content does not exist on there.
>> As a creator, you have to avoid uploading 18 plus content.
>> And you know, as parents, you should be protecting your
kids and making sure they're not watching any weird. >> Yeah.
But I mean, this is just like this muddying of the waters to
try and like slither away out of the situation. Cuz does it actually
matter that he clicked the yes, I'm 18 box when he's introducing
himself in the server and saying that he's 14 years old. >> Does
it really [clears throat] matter? >> Doesn't matter at
all. No. So anywh who, the point that I'm trying to make is um
>> yeah, I [__] up by having a not safe for
work server. I definitely regret that. But uh yeah. All right.
Calling me a for this is insane levels of slam.
>> He's just going to keep going back to lying about what
the actual allegations are over and over and over again. Lie,
lie, lie, lie, lie. Huh? Actually, some people on Patreon do
sell Nazi for Yeah, that's not the point, man. That's literally
not the point. >> I mean, it's an obvious straw, man. I
I I would doubt that he thinks you're actually calling a It's
just a smear to be able to get away with it, right? Trying to
paint out that you're making some excessive claim. >> It's
that persecution complex. that >> I have called I have
called Nakup in my tweets earlier but uh in my earlier tweets
but uh I have not said anything about it being a in that video.
>> So if he's trying to find you thorax
he's looking in the wrong place. Right.
We'll get that to Naco. We'll get that to Naco. Hopefully we
can get him to review your tweets live. Call him a
>> to note. Um, a lot of people, uh, because it's an 18
plus situation. If you have a Patreon, a lot of people actually
put not uncensored on their Patreon. All right, this is trash
taste popular anime podcast. All right, on their trash taste
show, get the uncensored version of episode 25, the the episode
and future uncensored episodes for $5 a month. All right. And
it's like,
yeah, cuz
you know, Patreon is an uncensored situation where you have to
be 18 to donate [__] All right. Um, also, no, but
you don't. You've just read the toos where it says explicitly,
we welcome users 18, sorry, 13 plus. So, you don't you don't
at all. I might have to double check. Is there no way that you
can explicitly mark a Patreon as 18 plus? I haven't. There definitely
has to be. There definitely has to be.
Let me see. Check it out. >> I'm pretty sure there should
be a way. >> If I want to go and edit my Patreon,
>> I'm not going to show it on screen. I'm not going to
show it on screen. If I want to go into the back end,
>> I mean, you can go on Patreon's website. You can go
on Patreon's website and just like see this. >> Hold on.
Send me a link to that >> cuz like I signed up for Naku's
Patreon. Unfortunately, I gave him a one single euro coin
which I then used to kill him. Uh, and I did not see any [__]
about it being an 18 plus, you know, thing.
>> Yeah, there's an adult category. Yeah, sure. And so
the issue here is Nux probably would never have selected this
18 plus [__] right? He never would have done that.
But
but the issue here is that the all the adult content is in the
Discord. It's not it's not a part of what you sign up for on
the Patreon. >> Dude, it's over. It's done. The 18 plus
categories for pages with one or more works. One or more, >> which
by the way, literally having an 18 plus category shows that it
is not an 18 plus implicitly website. Okay. >> Works including
depictions of human beings and animations containing explicit
content andor nudity. So, was that ever was his Patreon ever
designated as adult 18 plus category? >> I mean, you can
go and join Nastaku's Patreon for free and test if it's not going
to ask you, oh, is it 18 plus or not, but when I joined it, it,
you know, there was no indication of it being uh being a
>> of course there isn't. Nobody says it's that. If there
was, there'd be like all kinds of like censorship on a ton of
Like, uh, how would I put it? I'm pretty sure unless you've given
your age to Patreon, it wouldn't even show up for >> like
in any discovery or anything. >> Indication here anywhere
that it's 18 plus or anything of them, >> dude. 3,000 members.
That's crazy. >> You can you can see the join for free
or like see membership options. >> Unfortunately, and I
regret this because I told you many times I regretted making
this kind of content. And I've said this myself a long time ago.
Everyone did these videos. All right. PewDiePie, biggest YouTuber
on the platform at the time, was making Boku. >> So this
is him. This is him recycling a point he's made a billion times.
>> Is a point. Total point. This is
>> This is utter nonsense.
Um, this video is from 2015
and uh Bokuna like this was not a this was not a massive
>> He's saying everyone reacted. I mean, by itself, PewDiePie
makes it a massive
I It was a pretty big trend. I wouldn't be shocked if a lot of
creators have deleted their videos in this. If you watched anime
10 years ago on the internet, you knew about this thing, right?
You knew about it. I've never seen it either, but you knew about
this thing. You knew what this thing was. You knew it was like
disgusting at minimum. And there were a lot of memes and references
to it. >> Look at this thing. you've only got one video
or two videos as examples of like this massive trend.
And >> if you go on like Google Trends and look up Bunu
Pico, you can see the PewDiePie video spike and then it like
goes down. And if you compare that with like, you know, YouTube
searches in the United States with Naku
as another >> new oiler call react segment. Yeah, I don't
think so, man. I don't I don't think so, dog. Search. >> I
don't think so. You can see that bukun >> listen I I'm
already apparently Hassan's number one defender so I I can't
handle any more scrutiny than that. Okay I'm already
between that and my comments on people. All right I'm like basically
already canceled. I can't handle this one as well. >> Go
trends upwards after Naku starts making the review videos. >> So
even by that it doesn't work. I mean I haven't watched apparently
apparently Naku has probably watched that over and over again.
I don't know what kind of sensor job PewDiePie has done there.
Uh that would be the deciding factor, I guess. But I'm pretty
sure that you would say that's still wrong to do. >> I'm
pretty sure he keeps most of the explicit stuff off screen and
uh like he crops it quite extensively.
But that doesn't stop the harmful impact of it, which is that
there's a bunch of kids in the comments of that video who are
talking about like, "Ooh, I checked it out cuz you know the video
made me curious to look it up." I think the thing that separates
PewDiePie from anyone else and and a bunch of people from Nu
is the fact that they didn't make like a habit of doing this
content constantly such that like they would build an audience
and a reputation for it, right? Where the audience would perpetually
come back and find the like the source again and again and again.
There's like a way different thing going on, right, than what's
going on here.
So for Ducks to pull this up, it's like, yeah, okay, some people
did that once.
You made a whole channel out of it. That's obviously a totally
different thing. This is complete coke. >> Oh man. But
with PewDiePie, I don't know if this is like a oneoff or is this
something he's done over and over again, but like it doesn't
matter. Like the other boys did it as well. [clears throat] The
other boys did it as well. Who cares? >> Is uh that I never
reacted to even >> I mean if I mean it would be a valid
point if everybody was doing it. If everybody was doing something
that means it's not socially frowned upon. That means like unfortunately
that's just a fact, right? Like it's obviously not a taboo thing.
You could have a criticism for like everyone, but it is weird
to pick out, you know, this is why when you get people who are
on statues and from 300 years ago, you're like, they were a terrible
person. They own slaves. It's like, well, yeah, sure, but so
did everyone else. I don't know. Now, I find it ironic that people
like Hassan, all right, Hassan is going to show up and he's going
to call me a and call Tea.
>> Join the [__] Patreon Discord server. No,
he did not. No, he did not. Send me a screenshot of that right
now.
>> What? He's doing his own investigation. >> Apparently.
Apparently.
>> Listen, we need Agent Nuggets in here right [__]
now. >> Hey, Cam Nuggets. Welcome to the Nexus.
Is that an accurate photo of Cam
I don't hate I don't dislike this guy, but can I can we just
be real? Is that an accurate photo of Cam Nuggets? Is that a
representative photo of Cam Nuggets? I feel like I've seen his
YouTube videos and that's that doesn't really look like I don't
think that's who he is. Far be it from me is somebody who doesn't
show their face on the internet to make a criticism, but
I don't think that's true life right >> Who reacted with
the wave? Was that you? >> Uh that that's my dude. That's
the admin of this page, dude. [laughter] That's that's the guy
that's the guy who said the Naktaku um Naktaku didn't set up
the rules
only set up the rules on moderators after like uh the patrons
pulled their pledges.
[laughter] >> When Mr. Nuggets is on your case, you know
it's over, dude. Just pack that up. You're done. You're done.